mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
start with a semicircle
from the upper right corner carefully
fold a circular segment until it just
touches the diameter and divides the
diameter into lengths of four and two
the question is what is the length of
the folded line
i thank yenta for the suggestion the
problem is adapted from a belgian
mathematical olympiad
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to solve this problem we must use the
little gray cells
we start with a circular segment that is
reflected about line a b
the resulting circular segment is
tangent at point t
and divides the diameter into lengths of
four and two
the entire diameter will have a length
equal to 6.
label the center of this semicircle as p
the radius of the semicircle will be one
half its diameter and therefore it will
be equal to 3.
consequently pt has a length equal to
one
now consider the reflected or folded
circular segment
let's draw the circle containing the
circular segment
because the original circular segment
belong to a semi-circle of radius 3
the resulting circle will also have a
radius equal to 3.
furthermore the center of this circle
will exactly be the image of p about
line segment a b
you can see this because both are
equidistant from points a and b and
there are symmetry about line segment a
b
if we construct p prime t
it will be perpendicular to this
diameter and it will have a length equal
to 3.
we can therefore focus on just this
right triangle
we can calculate the length of the
hypotenuse using the gogu theorem and we
get the distance between the two centers
is equal to the square root of 10.
let's construct point c as the midpoint
of the hypotenuse
we can then get pc is equal to one-half
the square root of 10.
since c is exactly halfway between p and
p prime it will also be along line
segment a b
now let's construct the radius pa
since it's a radius of this semicircle
it will have a length of 3.
we will then focus on the right triangle
pac
we can calculate the length of ac using
the gogu theorem
we get the result of the square root of
26 all over 2.
we then go back to the diagram and we
can calculate the length of a b which
will be exactly twice ac
and therefore the length of the folded
line will be equal to the square root of
26 which is approximately 5.1
and that's the answer
i think it's a really neat problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you